che sono poi dei tagli su rep
era da un pò venuto registro perché sono
stato in vacanza nel mentre quindi
vediamo se sono usciti nuovi livelli
spero di sì credo di sì
la ruota del wow fare il primo acquisto
di me cos'è e tipo social face sono gli
schiaccia uniscono cose va bene alla
giustizia fisicamente la sto
schiacciando col mouse
va bene
pietro come minimo attenzione federico
benini un divano
ho trovato un divano africano ma come
africano federico benini non mi sa di
nome africano poteva andar peggio potevo
vincere un pitone una sedia il divano
forse una delle cose peggiori adesso che
ci vedo riproviamoci ragazzine non ho
capito se esce sempre divano sei
veramente una ruota che va a culo però
scommette un milione di dollari che
vincono milioni di dollari quindi alla
fine di mango con zero porca vacca
niente bon box grazie
ti prego maledizione ti prego
il divano roma il mike appello di mario
non fatemi domande
andiamo avanti attenzione questa buona
che separa me lo sento queste buone me
lo sento un milione di dollari e ho
perso perché gli os commessi quindi fa
niente under dei suns fight
veramente no manca la musica hanno
aspetta aspetta tra la metto eccoci a
posto non sto facendo niente sta
succedendo in italia sono morto
porca vacca vi faccio
e difficile non riesco a colpirlo
[Musica]
e va bene o attenzione
com'è possibile non muore così suns non
facciamo questi spoiler ma non muore
così rock swing 481 un classicone che da
un pochettino che dovrei prenderci la
mano click to skip sì perché non me ne
frega niente paolo friz come funziona
per niente tu devi lanciare la rom
ma cos'è ago proprio nei menu yngve sa
bene tu devi lanciare teoricamente la
roba e collage ferma però mi sa che ho
sbagliato a livello perché è
completamente diverso vi facciamo perché
tu ci sono i rossi infatti solo questi
due to lanci la corda o catena work e e
si ferma si frizza so che devi farli
tutti i consigli all'inizio alla fine
sono una figata pazzesca ma non c'entra
niente perché questo centro almeno a me
mi si è staccato un braccio però fa
niente vediamo se arriva alla fine lo
stesso anche perché il braccio mi serve
stavo scherzando ragazzi porte ai
signori ci siamo perfetti
o devo schiacciare il pallone non
seguire il cursore click skip cos'è che
sta succedendo lì cosa ma che ti che sul
livello raga non ho capito lo sta
succedendo
raga ma chi è che fa stimare un geniale
alla nuca smi ciao maci semmai anche o
cosa sto vedendo
mai ha fatto benissimo e livello più
bello che abbia mai visto su rock swing
ragazzi miglior rock kings della storia
ma a mani basse proprio mai fatto dati
io ma giuro non ho mai visto livello
fatto così bene dove devo andare
aiuto allora che si fa backflip get
liden perfetto anche la precisione l'ex
co sto entrando nel portale dove che
vado dove che vi fa apparire questo
merita di essere nella top livelli cola
di è più che scontato gioco merita tutto
completamente fatto da dio ma dov'è che
devo arrivare che sto facendo avanti e
indietro che non capitolo arrivare al
cosa di fianco a no mi fa andare avanti
ok texture plein a hope you like linea
knight day thank you die incognito si
dirà di no sei un genio zio cioè ve lo
giuro su dio
fattelo dire se è veramente un genio non
ho mai visto un livello fatto così bene
la prima volta ci sono questo qua batte
tutti
ma guarda
guarda cos'è sta roba 130 animals si
vola vabbè dai nove buche fatto da dio
veramente il più bel livello mai visto
su uno dei più belli in assoluto morto
trovato l'angolo su altro 3 tibelli
tegole un detto scherzavo non è per
niente male non è per niente male prima
non è tra i più belli sezione lui ti ha
rubato l'iphone xs va come mi stai
mentendo già non sto più mangiando da
quando ho comprato per risparmiare i
soldi porco demoni c'e anche su come la
botta sorella pure non so come ho fatto
a vincere non so come babbo natale si
sia incastrato ma mi piace sempre più
questo gioco gli avanti ragazzi proviamo
memorie non 99 per cento in poi si
voleva che non mi piglia un attimo e il
fatto era questo tipo di sfida che
cercavo amici miei
vi vedrete su questo livello per un po
di ore quindi tanto vale mettere una
canzone che è che ci piace
ecco che cercavo orco demonio i salti di
odessa un imposto alla mia eta beta
questa canzone in realtà non ve l'ho mai
detto
[Musica]
va bene
è tutto merito di megalomania comunque
sono fosse per quello di the ball prendi
la palla a devo colpire qualcosa con la
palla lancio lì è dove fini ma tra che
finisce a devo far canestro ma domanda
aspetta un attimo di un casinò
scherzavano nel parco demonio per niente
ma io posso lanciarmi andare a canestro
con la palla stessa
no perché sarebbe una figata incredibile
ma dai ma dai ma l'uso po di forza o
quelle buone
porco demonio
mi piace se così li vedo gli veloci un
attimo stephen curry for free con una
sega yo yo a basket ragazzi sono
veramente una terra
se ci se c'è un gioco in cui faccio
schifo e il basket c'è veramente non
riescono il canestro non lo centro
neanche per sbaglio proprio io coi buchi
occhio bus o facendo la roba stranissimo
aveva bene buono adesso lei o come
france o balconi utero al 4 ragazzi
hanno rifatto balconi of terror però
questa volta nuovo maicon in ferro per
chi non conoscesse è uno dei livelli ma
manco iniziato uno dei livelli più
conosciuti di happy meals perché
praticamente ti butti da sto balcone di
privare la fine intanto el hanno
modificato nel senso che hanno aggiunto
roba fantastico lezioso
c'è prima mente è un po sono morto ok è
un po diverso rispetto al solito balconi
opteron non so se riesco a fare anche
questo perché penso sia più difficile
forse devo cambiare personaggio ragazzi
non credo che valgono zero si possa fare
col nonno ciak impossibile col padre di
yuki sicuro ok ok piatto dato una
testata luke vinci non fa niente
mamma mia quanto lo hanno fatto
difficile sta versioni balconi in ferro
è veramente edificio va bè ragazzi
problema è che con la pc non riesco
veramente a direzionare mimando cadeau
porco demonio morto è veramente
impossibile
piano piano piano per la morte del cielo
e del gesù piano vai non andare sempre
facciamo una bellissima cosa quando
andiamo in basso andiamo direttamente a
destra così in un intercetto con la
stanza stupida la c'era qualcuno che
faceva gameplay comunque l'ho visto
bahia de a destra a destra per favore a
destra a destra perché sei scherzo eh
vabbè sono tornato di sopra va bene
cambiamo o babbo natale non lo uso tipo
mai però credo che in questo caso abbia
senso
perfetto fortuna che ci sono i folletti
che mi parlano il deretano non ce l'ho
fatto giocare a posto salve buongiorno e
niente sono morto parco demonio quanto
di successo livello non si sa come ma ho
vinto tecnici world mistica al nome
quindi va bè proviamoci
che figata che figlia poteva non farli
anche nuova per scendono pure potranno
farli anche colorati sti cosi sarebbe
stato molto più carino prova niente va
bene lo stesso baratz e avrei bisogno di
un aiuto visto che no vabbè per niente
devo arrivare ecco lo centra guardo lo
vedo lo vedo
e sempre molto strano quando mando steve
senza le gambe col poco perché non so
mai dove salto però vabbè fa niente
troviamo un altro livello va fatto
magari di favi j
se mi fanno la grazia miei ragazzi
vediamo un attimo hanno fatto la grazia
mi hanno fatto che grazie a fa vj e il
nesquik sono molto poco curioso però
proviamo signori spero che questo video
vi sia piaciuto dove al solito servizio
più lasciato un bel mi piace iscrivetevi
al canale schiacciate la campanella
prima età giornate fino ai video
soprattutto per certi bhatti che mi
stanno facendo si sa mai dove andrà a
finire i diavoli o avanti nella vita non
si sa mai cosa succede voi schiacciate
la parola campanellina sono lo sapremo
mai
e noi ci vediamo come sempre a un
prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]